This is the Reason Interview with
Nick Gillespie.
All right. Thanks for coming out,
this is part of Reason's Little
Singer series of
salons.
And our guest tonight is James
Kirchick, the author
most recently of the book "Secret
City: The Hidden History of Gay
Washington." We're going to be
talking to him about his work,
uh, and his career and his
commitments to free speech.
You define yourself Jamie, uh,
which is how you go by.
You define yourself as a free speech
absolutist.
Yeah.
Um, why don't we start by tell
me how, what does that mean?
Like, because you obviously
don't believe in free speech
always being
legal, do you?
I support the First Amendment of the
United States Constitution.
I've never heard of that.
Which is, uh, the most
expansive in terms of
any law of any country in the world
and basically permits any speech
that is short of
inciting imminent violence.
Or it could be or harassment.
Right?
Yeah. Short of that, um,
I think we should have a pretty wide
berth.
Uh, you, uh, recently turned 40
years old.
So you are, what, a millennial.
Technically, I turned 40.
Yes.
Uh, on the inside, you're obviously
much older.
Yeah.
Um. But why?
I mean, so millennials and even
worse, Gen Z, are there any Gen Z
in the audience?
Okay, look at one.
Uh, um, but,
um, why are you a free speech
absolutist? Your generation does not
believe in free speech anymore.
I mean, I, I maybe trace it back
to, I think when I was in sixth
grade and I read "1984"
and I wasn't really politically
aware of anything or much
until that point.
Um, and that book just sort of
opened up a world to me.
It sort of it taught me what the
Cold War was.
Uh, it was great literature.
It taught me what freedom meant to
taught me what authoritarianism was.
I think the next year I joined
Amnesty International, which was a
very different organization.
We're talking like almost 30 years
ago, was a very different
organization. It was mostly
concerned with...You
write letters to dictatorships
to free political prisoners.
So every week could be some new,
you know, uh, person
in some benighted land.
And it was literally you'd write
like, you know, "Dear, uh,
Comandante, uh, you know,
Juarez" or something like, 'Please
release this writer from
jail." Um,
and then I also actually
think, I think being a closeted gay
person from, you know, until I was
18.
I think your secret's out.
Not anymore.
Not anymore. But I think being in
the closet for, you know, until I
was 18, um,
taught me the value of
expression and honesty and
and speaking your truth.
I hate that term, but,
uh, well, because it's become
a sort of form of relativism.
You know my truth.
There is a truth, right?
But anyway, I think being,
um, uh, understanding
what it means to have to lie about
yourself, about something so
integral to who you are, it
just made me very sensitive to this
issue.
I mean, in my book "Secret City," I
compare sort of the plight
of gay men and women in America 50,
60 years ago to that of dissidents
in a communist country.
Because their
bars were raided by the police,
their phones were tapped by the FBI.
They had to live a lie.
They had to pretend to be something
that they weren't.
And so I really do think that being
gay and sort of, you know, suffering
in the closet in high school and
what not made me much more,
uh, supportive of free speech.
Um, I guess a couple things
while you're talking.
Um, I realize I have a lot
of bills that I need to pay.
Um, you know, other things in my
mind came up.
That was a joke that obviously
did not go over right.
You should host the Golden Globes.
Have you thought about that?
No, I turn that down for this, if
you can imagine.
Right.
Um. But, um.
What?
Why was it difficult to come out?
And what made it easy?
There...not easy, but what?
Well, I first of all, everything's
relative.
And, uh, you know, I, I
grew up in a very,
you know, pretty liberal, accepting
household. I was very lucky in that
sense.
I went to an all boys school, um,
which, you know, all male
environments tend to be more.
Homophobic.
And homophilic in a sense right.
Because it's all affiliated.
Yeah. My high school, unfortunately,
it was not it it was, uh,
um, but, you know, it's a kind of,
you know, bravado and, you know,
proving you're not gay is very much
a part of those kinds of
environments. I think a lot, by the
way, has changed in the
22 years since.
I mean, everyone's coming out now
at 12 or 13 it seems like.
Half, half of Gen Z is LGBT.
I don't believe that for a second,
by the way.
But that's what it says according to
the polls. It's actually, it's
incredible when you think of the
the dramatic change where being
gay or LGBT, queer,
whatever term you want to use, was
considered a bad thing,
a terrible thing, a sin and what not.